si la reunión de ministros de defensa de
la otan ha finalizado con un mensaje
claro de apoyo inquebrantable a Ucrania
y de hecho ha anunciado la gran mayoría
de países nuevos compromisos de envío de
equipamiento de defensa ante aérea el
secretario general de la otanstoltenberg
anunciado la entrega de cientos de
inhibidores de drones rusos pero también
iraní recordemos este tipo de drones son
los que han perpetrado la gran mayoría
de ataques en la última semana contra
principalmente la población civil y el
secretario general de
merca asegurado que esto podría ayudar a
paralizar gran parte de este tipo de
ataques además países comunes como en
España han anunciado el envío de
lanzadoras que ayuden en la defensa
también ante aérea de Ucrania ahora
mismo la defensa antiaérea es una de las
prioridades del país pero ahora mismo
con la ayuda Ucrania en los países
aliados también están viendo mermadas
sus almacenes de municiones y por ello
los países han acordado poder aumentar
estos almacenes empezar ya con una serie
de lista de o prioridades para poder
aumentar estos almacenes que ahora mismo
están descendiendo también han acordado
Un aumento de la protección de
infraestructuras críticas tras los
sabotajes de los gasoductos noxtrimono y
nostrindos de hecho James ha recordado
que ya se ha Doblado la presencia en el
mar Báltico para proteger estas
infraestructuras y finalmente como
comentabas en los márgenes de esta
reunión una quincena de países de la
otan liderados por Alemania sobre todo
el centro y del norte de Europa han
decidido la creación de este escudo
antimisiles que sirve de ayuda también
para el escudo antimisiles que ya existe
para proteger a toda la alianza Pero
según el gobierno Alemán trataría de
proteger todas estas lagunas ahora mismo
el escudo antimisiles que existe para
proteger a la alianza sirve sobre todo
para hacer frente a misiles de largo
alcance provenientes de
Irán pero también
de Corea y que se encuentra en Turquía